[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on Thursday the 19th of
October I'm Kate Andrews the spectator's
economics editor and your host this week
coming up on the
show is this the start of a new world
order with Wars breaking out in Ukraine
and now in the Middle East has the world
become too reliant on the assumption
that America will always intervene
Israeli journalist Jonathan spire and
former US defense secretary Richard H
join me to
discuss can the UK look forward to tax
cuts in the next government it's going
to be tricky The Institute for fiscal
Studies released its green budget this
week and the report makes for Grim
reading Paul Johnson chief of the ifs
joins me on the show the global birth
rate is falling why are women having
fewer children and to what extent is
this really a problem joining me to
discuss is The Spectators Mary Wakefield
and Steven J Shaw and finally is
chivalry dead and if so who is to blame
Laura dodsworth has written about this
for spectator life this week I'll chat
to her on the show before we get going
if you like spectator TV do subscribe to
our YouTube channel thousands are
joining our Channel every week and you
should be one of them just click the
Subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and tap the Bell icon to make sure
you never miss an episode I would also
like to thank our sponsors canor genuity
Wealth Management experienced wealth
planners and investment managers who
offer unwavering support during
challenging times to find out more visit
KW wealth.com for more
information first up for the cover piece
this week Jonathan Spire takes a look at
the new world order as the violence
continues in the Middle East and Ukraine
are we beginning to see America's World
Order crumble and Iran Le politics
making gains Jonathan joins me now
alongside former US defense secretary
Richard
Hass Jonathan and Richard thanks for
joining me joh Jonathan you are
currently based in Israel can you give
us an
update yes it's not a I mean obviously
the main event of the last 24 hours has
been the visit of President Joe Biden
but in terms of the broad
situation uh there are still 300,000
Israeli reservists mobilized they are in
their great majority currently waiting
on the border with Gaza there is still
uh air action Israeli air action over
Gaza and something which I think has not
been sufficiently noted in global
coverage uh is that the situation in the
north on Israel's border with Lebanon is
also extremely tense there have been
several launches today of anti-tank
missiles by the Lebanese hisb
organization at positions of the Israel
Defense Forces one of them in a place
called Shah uh there were a number of
people a number of service people
wounded so the situation to the north is
also extremely tense so I think those
are the main points I would raise just
in terms of an immediate update Jonathan
thank you for that update you write the
cover piece for this week's magazine
about the New World Order suggesting
that history is moving Iran's way can
you talk us through
it well my sense uh as someone who's
been looking at the region living in the
region covering the region now for quite
a few years is that the main beneficiary
of a number of historic events underway
in the Middle East over the last decade
and a half to two decades has been the
Islamic Republic of Iran specifically
the breakdown or fragmentation or even
partial collapse of governance in a
whole number of arabic speaking states
of of quite long historic standing and
specifically I would point to Lebanon
Syria Iraq and to some degree Yemen also
where go Central governance has to some
degree broken down and the Iranian
practice the irgc Islamic revolutionary
guards calls methodology and practice of
irregular warfare namely the
construction of or support for uh
political-military
organizations in neighboring countries
has proven to be a remarkably useful uh
method for the implanting of political
power and influence in those uh
collapsed spaces so the loss of the
Palestinian Authority of control of the
Gaza Strip in 2007 and and its loss of
to the Hamas organization is a local
variant of a process which is visible
across the region and which has in its
total uh brought to the Islamic Republic
of Iran a previously unprecedented level
I would say of influence and power
across broad spaces uh in the region and
the current I would say events regarding
Gaza are a product of that process in
the sense that regardless of whether
Iran sort of pulled the trigger or was
in control tactically of the events of
October 7th which we don't know probably
will never know the Kamas military
capacity and ability comes from and only
from the relationship with Islamic
Republic of Iran based on the uh broader
Regional Str strategy which I just tried
to outline Richard as a former Defense
secretary what do you make of Jonathan's
comments there do you think that history
is headed Iran's way and is America
still the global policeman of the
world well there's lots in there I don't
think America ever was quote unquote the
global policeman of the world uh even at
the height of its uh influence there
were many things going on the world that
the United States was not in a position
to to control but clearly we're living
in a world of more distributed power uh
and the United States has uh experienced
shall we say quite a few setbacks in the
Middle East obviously uh most apparently
in Iraq and also the United States now
is somewhat more focused Elsewhere on
Europe and on what's now called the uh
Indo Pacific in terms of the region
itself I think it what Jonathan laid out
is is true in the sense that Iran has
increased its influence significantly uh
across the region from from Yemen
through Iraq and Syria to Lebanon at the
same time Iran can't be happy with the
Abraham Accords uh with the the growth
of acceptance of the reality of Israel
in the region Iran is also suffered all
sorts of internal political and economic
uh
difficulties in in in recent years and
what was about to happen uh
interestingly enough was a a
breakthrough between Israel and Saudi
Arabia a certain uh United States and
Iran entering into a kind of modus Fendi
that is all blown up by events of the
last 10 days or so so we'll now see how
this uh we'll see how this plays out but
suddenly there's there's much more
uncertainty uh and unfortunately much of
it is a negative and it's easier to see
how this war widens and how more
problems come to the Middle East then
somehow this is a uh an unlikely waste
Station to to progress
Richard you wrote in foreign affairs
that you think Washington should try to
restrain military action in Gaza what
practically speaking would that look
like I think it looks like what
President Joe Biden is saying and doing
in Israel what he's doing is balancing
support for Israel and it's right to do
certain things but essentially saying
even though you have the right to do
certain things even though your emotions
are telling you to do those things you
might want to think twice or three times
before doing them the United States has
clearly pushed back against the quote
unquote Siege of Gaza Gaza the cutting
off of water and fuel electricity and so
forth the United States has already
pushed back against that and clearly the
United States is counseling restraint
and if I had to summarize the American
policy it's go after Hamas but don't go
after Gaza basically choose something
that's much more uh Discerning in what
you do so rather than going big going
small small whether it's from the air or
from the ground and my my guess is that
will be closer to what ultimately
happens that I think there's a lot of
Israelis who also have fundamental
doubts about the wisdom of going ahead
with a large ground operation all the
costs all the international outcry the
possibility it would lead to war
widening and then at the end of it it's
not clear again how you establish
political Authority in in Gaza Israel
Israel saw that in 2005 and it's not at
all obvious to most observers that if
they went in big now and then left they
would have a lot to show for it Jonathan
what do he make of Joe Biden and
America's handling of the current crisis
yeah I think what uh the administration
is trying to do and I I agree with
Richard on this is to both uh support
Israel but also to try to uh restrain uh
I think that the the dispatching of the
two or the aircraft carrier USS Gerald
Ford and now Dwight de eisenh her is
heading there as well the USS Dwight
eisenh her is is deeply significant and
this is I think clearly an attempt to
say to Iran and hisbah you know as the
president himself has said well don't
get involved um placing Iran and hisb in
before quite a dilemma in a certain
sense because they've been talking in
recent years now for what they call the
unification of the Arenas or unification
of the fronts which is supposed to
represent this notion of a kind of
United group of islamist uh paramilitary
movements behind Iran under Iran's
leadership directed against Israel and
if Israel now does go into Gaza in a
major way and Iran then does not
intervene they will look somewhat
weakened in the Middle Eastern context
having not sort of backed up a great
deal of rhetoric in recent years at the
same time with the USS General Ford
there Gerald Ford there in the
Mediterranean Iran would be exercising
taking the real chance of uh tussling
with you know United States military
response so that will place them in a
dilemma as well I agree I think the
administration doesn't appears to be
seeking to avoid a major operation on
the ground the government of Israel we
should be clear has stated as its goal
the removal of Hamas political Authority
in uh Gaza it took a few days to say
that for a while it was sort of not
quite clear and different Minister
saying different things it has now set
it at the top levels H if that is indeed
the the serious intention of the
government of Israel it's very difficult
to see how that could be carried out uh
other than by a major ground operation I
agree also that it's not at all clear
because Israel has not made it at all
clear what would replace Hamas governing
Authority in Gaza that's something which
the government of Israel I think more or
less on the record said well we don't
know we're not we've not given that a
vision thought yet which is not
necessarily uh you know which is not
clarifying either so that's a goal if
Israel wants that it will have to carry
out an operation on the ground and I
tend to agree that the Americans and
others appear to be counseling against
that I guess we're going to find out in
the days the head what will take place
you can't keep 360,000 uh people
permanently mobilized right that's how
many reservist Israel has has mobilized
you can't keep them in in uniform you
know indefinitely so something has to
move and has to happen uh fairly close
in the fairly close future I would say
Richard you said on Twitter that
President Biden's speech from Israel was
quote nothing less than masterful others
have been more critical especially about
his use of of the phrase other team when
he B basically used the word team others
have suggested it wasn't the most
thoughtful phrase I'm I'm curious as to
uh what has won over your praise for
that speech What specifically do you
think he's getting
right people can focus on little things
like his use of the word team but the
the overall thrust of the speech I
thought tried to thread a needle on one
hand he's trying to I think rightly and
understandably support Israel in the
wake of these Savage attacks and Israel
has the right and as he's often said the
duty to respond terrorism cannot be
allowed to be conducted with impunity
that's it on the other hand he is trying
to essentially counsel Israel he's
trying to temper its rage and he wants
them to go in a a much more refined sort
of way again as I said before to focus
on Hamas not not Gaza and that's a
difficult balance uh he's got a lot of
popularity in Israel he's banked a lot
of good wealth from his earlier uh
Speech and from American Aid and and so
forth and I think so far at least he's
pulling off this very difficult
balancing trick it speech was both
filled with personal Reflections also
had a lot of substantive policy he
announced uh the aid humanitarian Aid
package for for the people of Gaza so
it's interesting that the policy here is
quite subtle and whereas some of the
rhetoric is more shall we say uh quote
unquote pro-israel but but the actual
substance of what he's he's doing I
think is is is quite uh measured and I
don't think he would disagree with a lot
of what Jonathan and I have been saying
about the the doubts about the wisdom of
going in llarge this idea of eradicating
Hamas I just don't think it's physically
doable or politically doable with
military instruments and even if somehow
you were able to capture a lot of their
leadership the next day something like
it would fill the political vacuum it's
not like the Palestinian Authority or
Arab governments are ready to to step in
so I think I think what ultimately if we
can somehow contain this crisis we're
probably gonna have to deal with a Hamas
with a Hamas controlled Gaza for some
time to come and then the question is
will Israel and others find a way to
moderate hamas's Behavior not because
Hamas has changed but through
deterrence Jonathan the Abraham and
courts were mentioned briefly at the
start of our conversation is anything
left of the Arab and Israeli repres
approachment oh very much so I mean I
think first of all it's important to be
aware that none of the countries which
which signed on to the Abraham Accords
and most significantly of course United
Arab Emirates have pulled out as a
result of the events of the last 11 days
and I don't expect that that will happen
I'm very much not so so the general
Trend with regard to that historic
process is still there H in a certain
sense the events of the last days don't
in any way push against the dynamic of
the Abraham records because in many ways
the Abraham records were
specifically a notion of bringing
together countries opposed jointly
opposed to precisely the kind of
politics and the kind of uh of military
uh Behavior if I can put it that way
represented since October 7th that's to
say United Arab Emirates famously is
most U primarily worried deeply worried
about the Muslim Brotherhood and about
Sunni islamism across the region Hamas
is a manifestation of precisely that
style of politics so October 7th and
what's happened since doesn't in any way
negate the logic of the Abraham Accord
in many ways on the contrary it
precisely strengthens at least the
security and defense element of the
Abraham Accords which was a very very
significant underlying uh factor and in
this sense you know I agree that of
course the roson hope for with with
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia will now not be
happening along the same timeline but
the logic of close connection between
Israel and Saudi Arabia is reinforced I
would say by the events of the recent of
recent days can just say also with
regard to the issue of Hamas and
removing its Authority you're absolutely
right of course that as a political
movement it's not possible to destroy a
political movement or a political Trend
using military power governing
authorities of course can be destroyed
using military power on the ground and
history is repete with examples of that
so in this sense you know the doability
of the goal Israel has said itself is
there you can do it if you're prepared
to expend sufficient amount of energy
and money and lives on the task as to
whether Israel will indeed undertake
that stated now stated goal in today's
head sure we don't know but you know
there is a coherence to the desire to
destroy Kamas political Authority if you
want to pay the price for it what is not
yet coherent in the Israeli case is that
the government has simply not related to
what should and would come next and
that's surely a question that must uh
must be asked Richard what do he make of
that again um the biggest problem is
what would come next and even if somehow
you could
root out Hamas again I'm not sure that's
possible because it's as much of an idea
and an ideology and a network and a
movement and the mere process of rooting
them out in some ways we create more
converts but the larger point is true
and there's the problem after 2005 a
political vacuum would be there I don't
see anyone from the outside ready and
able to fill it the Palestinian
Authority can't even really govern the
West Bank how is it going to govern uh
Gaza the Arab world really wants no no
part of it the quote unquote
International Community lacks the
capacity and and uh and the will and the
consensus to do it so again I just don't
see it as a as a serious short-term
alternative in the long run I'd love to
see Hamas marginalized but I think
that's going to require a whole
different political track to the
Palestinian issue and basically show the
Palestinians who are willing to rule out
force and live with Israel compromised
to reach some kind of a coexistence that
they will accomplish much more by going
down that path than Hamas will by
rejection and violence but that's
something that will take years or
decades uh to work out and that's
something that could only begin once the
dust settles here Richard you've
predicted before a new era of disorder
due to the muting of us dominance but
critics might say that it was the us
over militarization that led to such
conflicts in the first place what would
you make of
that look the United States did
overreach and certain cases clearly in
Iraq and to some extent in in
Afghanistan but the idea that uh the
United States is responsible in large
part for disorder in the world is
preposterous that's just ideology I'm
not sure if it's coming from the far
left the far right or or or both I think
historians will be critical of what the
United States has done over the last 30
years uh when it came out from the cold
war with tremendous opportunities and I
don't think in some ways we've made good
on that uh on those opportunities but in
many cases it's for what we haven't done
rather than for what we've done and
there's no way you can attribute uh Mr
Putin's uh violent war against Ukraine
to what the United States has done or
now what Hamas has done or you know the
rise of Chinese power is simply a
function of of Chinese society and
economic uh growth the world deserves a
lot of blame for what hasn't been done
on global issues like climate change so
again this this criticism of the United
States I think says a lot more about
those doing the criticizing than it does
about historical reality and Jonathan
just to finish uh back to your cover
piece on that New World Order how much
of that world order can be attributed to
the Changes in Attitude in places like
America but really across the West when
it comes to militarization and the
appetite for these countries to get
involved in other
conflicts yes I think that that is a
very notable uh fact Factor that's to
say if we thinking of the Middle East at
least you know the sense of a declining
willingness of the West and of the
United States in particular to to
respond to security threats if we think
for example of the attack on Saudi
Arabian oil processing facilities by the
Iranians through a proxy in September
2019 you know as one example of the
sense that countries in the region have
had of a a declining willingness of
America and that but yeah I think that
processes can be attributed to that I
think for example the Abraham Accords in
some ways was a coming together of
countries traditionally aligned with the
United States who jointly had become
aware that the United States itself
didn't want any more involvement in land
and Upstream in the Middle East so to
speak and that therefore were required
to make their own sort of uh uh you know
links to one another I do think that's
right I would say also um with regard to
what's taking place in in Gaza just now
that when we talk about various this is
not quite in terms of the question you
asked but just in terms of the earlier
discussion I think it's important for us
to note when we talk about Alternatives
that October 7th was also a result of a
failure of an existing policy and that
policy was the attempt to seek to
coexist with uh continued Hamas rule in
Gaza so whilst undoubtedly as we've been
discussing there are major difficulties
associated with any project of replacing
Hamas in Gaza it is also the case as
we've seen so graphically demonstrated
over the last 12 days that coexist
existing with Hamas Authority in Gaza
May well be an impossibility if at least
we wish as indeed we of course do wish
to provide security for the residents of
of Israel's South so I think that's
something which didn't quite come up in
the discussion which I wanted also just
to uh to put out there Jonathan and
Richard thanks so much for joining
me next the economy The Institute for
fiscal studies has described the UK as
stuck in a horrible fiscal bind trapped
in a cycle of low growth and high debt
interest payments what can political
parties offer before the next election
is there any chance of tax cuts joining
me to discuss the state of the economy
as the head of the institute for fiscal
studies Paul
Johnson Paul thanks for joining me the
ifs's green budget which assesses the
economic climate ahead of the
Chancellor's Autumn statement was
published this week it makes for very
Grim reading summed up by the UK being
in a horrible fiscal bind can you talk
us through the
headlines yeah I mean the bind
essentially is this which is that we've
got taxes at the moment um and heading
to their highest level ever so you might
think that means we've got lots of money
lots of money to spend um but we don't
um and part of the reason for that is
that growth has been slow part of the
reason for that is actually spending has
risen a fair bit over this Parliament
part of the reason is that um we've
stopped being able to save money on
things like defense which we've saved
money on in the past and part of the
reason we're just spending so much on
debt interest um around 100 billion
pounds a year at the moment and it's
going to steady off at something like 3%
of national income a lot higher than
it's been for a long long time uh with
the which means we're spending more on
debt interest than we are on any public
service other than the NHS you put all
of that together with the high debt
levels we start with and even with those
high levels of tax our overall level of
debt is stuck it's not going down and of
course both the chancellor and the
shadow Chancellor say they're committed
to getting our debt down over over a
parliament Paul to pick up on that point
about debt I noticed that the ifs's
green budget was quite critical of
Chancellor Jeremy Hunt's current fiscal
rule which is supposed to see debt
falling as a percentage of GDP by the
fifth year of a forecast but that is on
a rolling basis it is the definition of
moving the goalpost because uh you know
you're always rolling over those years
so in theory you could be making this
pledge but never actually having to see
debt fall as a percentage of GDP I I
noticed that the green budget dug into
this a little bit and I like your
thoughts on this because those fiscal
rules are set to keep government
accountable whether that be in terms of
tax promises tax cuts or in terms of
more giveaways it's supposed to keep the
treasury on track do you think this
fiscal rule is keeping things on track
why do we have fiscal rules we have
fiscal rules partly because there's
always a Temptation if you're the party
Empower to tax less or spend more
because that's always popular that
pushes up debt and borrowing over time
you want some way of gaining credibility
both with the outside world and the
markets and we saw how important that
was a year ago but also actually with
your colleagues I mean the most
important role in many ways of a fiscal
rule is as a way of saying no to all of
those secretaries of State who come
asking for billions more for for for
what they're for what they're doing so I
think you do need a way of really
constraining what you're doing the
problem with the rule that we've got at
the moment is that it's resulted in some
both some uh I think bad policy so the
chancer announced a change to
corporation tax in the March budget
which he said is only there for three
years because he couldn't afford it
within his rules for a couple more years
that just creates uncertainty it also
means that we have some sort of fictions
frankly in the um forecast because it's
all based on forecast not where we are
at the moment so the fiction that fuel
duties for example will go up every year
we've had that fiction every year for
the the last 13 years and it has proved
to be fictional for every one of those
um 13 years so you need to find a way of
having a rule which is which is binding
um which is sensible uh which constrains
government which also has enough
flexibility that you don't have this
silly situation where you're uh playing
around with them now there is no perfect
fiscal rule what you actually want is
the perfect Chancellor who's just going
to do the sensible thing uh but absent
that um a commitment I think to to in a
more General sense to get debt down over
the medium term rather than that
specific year it would be more helpful
Paul sometimes I wonder if politicians
including in the conservative party are
still in the pandemic mindset where they
just want to spend and spend money uh as
if there are no consequences to that
obviously we're in a very different
world now especially since interest
rates have gone up quite significantly
to historically uh normal levels but
very significant from from where we were
it strikes me that rishy cck and and
Jeremy Hunt do understand uh that fiscal
credibility and fiscal hawkishness is
somewhat necessary right now but I also
look at stated versus revealed
preferences and the government talks a
lot about tax cuts and how much it
wishes it could deliver it but what it
actually does is hike spending uh and
this government has increased spending a
lot uh over uh the course of even just
this year and that's something I think
the ifs green budget speaks to well I
think there's um a couple of things
going on you're right I mean if you look
back at the March budget the big thing
in that budget was a five billion
increase in spending on child almost a
new whole new leg of the welfare state
and if you look actually over the period
of this Parliament it's an entirely
different picture from what you got in
the 2010 so the 2010s were really tough
on uh departmental spending period since
2019 we've actually seen if anything
faster than average growth in public
spending over that period now partly
that's obviously a reaction against the
the cups that we saw during um during
the 2010s uh looking forward given the
precious on health um and pensions and
so on I think we might expect spending
to rise further actually the biggest
arguably the biggest fiscal announcement
of my lifetime outside of Crisis was the
NHS Workforce plan published in I think
it was June this summer just that
Workforce plan if it's carried through
will add 2% of national income to our
spending and therefore our tax into the
into the medium run and I think actually
sort of getting to grips with the scale
of that and deciding actually whether we
want to be in the medium run a higher
tax higher spending economy than we have
historically been or to be at the kind
of levels we have historically been at
but if we're going to do the latter then
we really do need to focus you much
harder or be much clearer about where um
actually you can make those cuts
relative to where we are or relative to
plans and that of course is tough well
no one wants to talk about that Paul and
the ifs does worked on this the office
for Budget responsibility does work on
this noting that from mid 2030s onwards
public spending is expected to go
through the roof if you're not going to
make changes in reform particularly to
the health care service and to the state
pension but those are two things that
politicians in particular are not
supposed to talk
about no it's uh it's really hard from
that point of view I mean relative to
most other European countries and indeed
actually relative to the us we do spend
less on state pensions partly because
our pension is quite low and we expect
people to build on that with their priv
own private saving the NHS is pretty
average internationally in terms of how
much we spend on it and alongside all
other countries that amount is rising um
now at one level that's not surprising I
mean there's no point in having money or
being rich if you're not healthy or
indeed not alive so it's not surprising
that people want to spend more overtime
on that but it is a big Choice it does
mean that we're spend we're you if we
carry on down this path then not only
will taxes stay at their highest level
that they have literally ever been in
this country but they will probably go
up even further or they could well go up
um even further and that that that is a
choice um and you know the sorts of
choices if you're looking at the um NHS
that you could could have there I'm not
suggesting you should but you could move
to a world in which more people or more
procedures are paid for privately I
slightly worry that we might even be
drifting into that by accident it's
clear that these our numbers are small
but at the moment more people um than a
few years ago are just deciding to pay
for their own um health care because
waiting lists are so high and so on I
think what we definitely need to do is
not drift into something like that if
that's a choice that we're going to make
then it's a choice we should make well I
think that's an important point right is
that these conversations actually have
to happen rather than it happening to us
I think if you look at government only
spend when it comes to oecd countries
the UK even at the highest of the
austerity years is in the top five
countries because a decision is being
made that this is going to be almost
solely publicly funded and publicly run
um as you say it's it's very normal
especially as people are living for
longer and want a higher quality of care
to demand more money if spent on
Healthcare but what we're seeing as you
say almost almost accidentally or like
it's happening to us is this drift
towards having say a health care service
or a pension service with a government
attached um and this is not something
that affects simply this government
whoever is elected next year whoever is
elected in 10 years time is going to
probably be facing these same
problems yeah the these are problems
that aren't going to go away and they
are um I mean they are really are common
to the developed world and they're
getting in in a sense at the moment
they're more pressing than ever because
it really does look like post coid we've
had a pretty serious drop in
productivity within the Health Service
and again it's harder to get that
evidence in other countries but there
may be some of that going on elsewhere
where so Health spending has risen over
this Parliament um you at sort of its
its long run average rate that means we
have more doctors and we have more
nurses and we have more money um in the
Health Service but the Health Service
isn't actually doing a great deal more
now during the 2010s on the way that you
measure these things productivity did
appear to rise but we've seem to have
lost a lot of that now that might be
because of um you know staff dis
disengagement and disaffection it might
be because of the way things are being
managed um it might because there is
still some coid knocking around and the
cost that that puts on hospitals but the
reason that we've got such big waiting
lists is not that many more people are
joining them it's actually that fewer
people are coming off them and that is a
reflection of the fact that the NHS
still still seems to be struggling um to
keep up the same level of activity uh
that it was pre pandemic so so I think
this this issue in a sense has come to a
head um over the last few years in quite
an unexpected way I me it it it's more
of a sort of immediate sort of um urgent
issue whereas it was uh for a long time
it was something that we could see
gradually coming towards us Paul I want
to talk to you about the tax burden
because in the green budget the ifs
notes that then Chancellor rishy sunac
decision to freeze tax thresholds is now
set to pull 6.5 million more people into
income tax by 2027 and I think 4.5
million more people into the higher tax
rate um this amounts to it uh the ifs as
a colossal 52 billion pounds a year tax
increase U there are Myriad of issues
with this uh there are political issues
for the Tory party which is
significantly raising the burden of tax
and I think you hit the nail on the head
earlier when you said people expect to
get something for that money but they
don't feel like they're getting
something for that money either they are
on that 7.6 million waiting list for the
NHS or their Public Services simply
aren't good enough or their child was
sent home from from school because the
building was falling apart at the start
of the school year it's one thing to
raise taxes it's quite another to raise
taxes and to not feel the additional
benefits of
that yeah I think that's I think that's
that that's fair I mean it is a very big
tax rise you can see why governments go
for that kind of tax rise because it's
it's less visible than other things
there isn't any month to month by which
your income goes down as a result of
this but it is meaning that people's
take hope that people's real earnings or
real incomes is one of the things that's
going to be holding them down over the
next few years and indeed has has held
them down but yes it
partly it reflects the all of the
pressures that we've been talking about
but those pressures are not pressures to
make things lot better they're pressures
really just to keep things running or in
some cases running less well than they
than they were and that of course is
going to you know that that that is not
nice mix it's part of this horrible
fiscal bind we started the conversation
off with where you've got more tax part
of the reason you've got more tax is
because we're spending so much more on
debt interest as I said well no one gets
any benefit from us spending a 100
billion a year on debt interest um and
because of the fact we we've run out of
ways of um sort of holding back the dam
in terms of long running pressures on
the welfare state we that for decades by
cutting and cutting and cutting defense
spending the state withdrew from a bunch
of things in the 1980s we had a decade
of austerity in the 2010s we've run out
of ways to do that and the pressure
alongside the low growth and the high
interest rates has finally burst that
Dam in actually quite a sudden way it it
really has and now they're being forced
to reckon with some of those issues as
we said they they don't want to talk
about um one area I wanted to press you
on Paul in the green budget is
chancellor Jeremy Hunt has been
insisting this year that now is not the
time for tax cuts for many reasons but
one of the reasons that has been
suggested is that tax cuts at this point
might be inflationary and the
government's priority has been to bring
inflation down so now is not the time to
see the rate Rise um and the ifs
somewhat backs this up by saying now is
not the time for an economic Sugar Rush
of tax cuts would modest tax cuts really
be inflationary at this point not least
when you consider that you know up until
very recently real wages for the better
part of two years fell under the rate of
inflation sometimes quite significantly
so would a marginal tax cut really be
inflationary or would it just help
people to pay the bills a bit more
comfortably well I guess it's um I I
mean you you you you stated the sort of
um problem at the end there really that
anything that is going to have a
significant effect on people's capacity
to pay the bills is probably not going
to be that marginal now you obviously if
it's a two billion pound tax cut that's
not going to be inflation that's not
going to make very much difference at
all there comes a point maybe it's at
the 20 billion pound level where that's
getting on for 1% of national income
where it probably would uh you know
pumping that additional amount of money
into the economy uh might be risky and
you whether it's inflationary or not you
might worry that the bank of England
would respond um worrying that it's
inflationary by increasing um by
increasing interest rates so you that
that's a fine job I would not be in the
least bit surprised if we find probably
not in the Autumn statement but in a
spring budget that the chanc will find
some way of having some kind of headline
tax cut maybe matched by a less obvious
tax increase elsewhere but I think it's
worth saying two things beyond that
anything that the government might do to
cut taxes particularly if it is as you
say relatively modest one will still
leave this probably the biggest tax
increase in Parliament in history um and
none of it really helps with the other
issue we've been talking about which is
that the public finances are in a
difficult um position so if you do have
a tax cut pre election and I think we've
seen this before the chances are that
one way or another it'll be undone post
election Paul uh my last question uh you
bring out the green budget once a year
you're going to face a little bit of
competition this year from Liz trust's
growth commission which is set to bring
out their growth budget next month also
ahead of the Autumn statement are you
ready for the
competition I think we're try we're
trying to do different things I mean
we're setting out um in a sense setting
out the facts the options um and the
constraints for the chancel and my
presumption is that the uh this um this
this this trust growth uh budget will be
setting out some fairly strong
statements about what needs to be done
from her point of view um now you know
we're all for growth and indeed you know
I've written and broadcast quite a lot
about the set of things that you need to
do to achieve growth and I hope that uh
within that we see some things on
infrastructure investment competition
planning reform and all those sorts of
things one thing that uh you know one
thing that results from the conversation
we've just had is if if the center of
this is tax cuts um and we all want
lower taxes everything else equal there
has to be some um equal and opposite or
roughly equal and opposite plausible
suggestions for spending cuts now if
there are equal and opposite plausible
suggest of spending cuts it would be
really quite interesting to see what
they are and what the impact that would
be so we await that with some interest
certainly well from memory it was the
spending Side Of The Ledger that was
missing from last year's many budgets so
we'll be uh all waiting to see if it's
included in this year's growth budget
Paul thanks so much for joining
spectator
T the global birth rate is falling in
the UK 900,000 adults last year
celebrated their 50th birthday while
700,000 births were recorded this is
considered to be a 23% deficit or birth
Gap in Italy and Spain it's 55% Japan
and South Korea are set to have one new
worker for every three future retirees
what's Behind These falling rates
joining me to discuss is the spectators
Mary Wakefield and data scientist Steph
J
Shaw Stephen and Mary thanks for joining
me on spectator TV Stephen for the
magazine this week you write about the
fall in the global birth rate and you
talk about the Practical and personal
impacts of this Western countries in
particular are facing a huge problem in
the future people have become accustom
them to certain levels of Public
Services certain levels of spending
especially as they get older in terms of
their pensions and their healthare and
practically speaking the way things are
going you're going to have a fewer
number of workers who can provide the
cash for those people in their old
age that's certainly true and I I don't
think we fully realize how much we rely
on current workers to support our aging
our aging population so you know we we
think for example that most State
pensions come from the money that we are
paying into Pension funds as we work for
most countries that's not the case
current people are paying the pensions
of the current retirees and then of
course as I mentioned the whole uh cost
of the NHS in UK is completely weighted
towards the elderly population so I I
don't think we've yet understood the
financial impact that this is going to
have that's such an important Point
Stephen people assume that they're
paying into their own pots that the
money will be there down the line but
these are pay as you go systems
essentially and it it might be the case
that the money isn't there in the future
um in your piece you talk about some of
the policies that governments have tried
to implement to encourage people to have
children but you note that none of these
have been terribly
successful no um in fact there's
absolutely none that we can say identify
that consistently we see will be
guaranteed to work in fact we can almost
say the exact OB it we can say things
will'll be guaranteed not to work what
we do find is that there are some
short-term increases and those are
usually people who are going to have
children anyway taking advantage of
whatever benefit might be on offer um so
the the issue is really not directly
about a bonness simply to have a child
mothers are having people are having
their children they want to have it's
about the basics it's about having the
core uh surroundings the home the
environment and the right time of life I
guess as well all those things are quite
difficult for uh you know any single
policy to address Mary what do you make
um about this idea of of the
government's job and encouraging people
to have children is that something
government should be doing do you think
it's some something government ever can
meaningfully do I mean I was fascinated
by Steven's piece because um his data
seems to suggest that government can't
incentivize people to have kids so from
my perspective you know you see all
these sort of pronatalist movements
starting up and conferences and everyone
interested in the baby bust now um and
yet we know from from people like Steven
that it just doesn't work
so from my perspective you need to look
at it from a from another angle which is
why ask yourself first um ask people who
wanted to have children but didn't why
that was the case why didn't they get to
have kids and Mary one of the people
making those points is you you wrote a
uh beautiful and personal column a few
weeks back for The Spectator about your
own experience with motherhood and some
thoughts that you've been reflecting on
can you share those with us yes um I've
got one child who I adore and Lavish Way
Too Much attention on
um but looking back on it you know I
would have liked to have had more um so
I was asking myself the question why
didn't I why did I leave it too late um
to have more really and
um it just occurred to me I never
thought that it would be too late no one
had warned me it would be too late that
wasn't um what we were told in school we
were just told about how great sex was
and the important of contraception and
this sort of thing it wasn't in my mind
that it would ever be too late that came
as a shock to me and I wondered really
if Steven had found other women who um
who didn't manage to have kids at all
who felt that this was a similar shock
to
them Stephen many many many and it's
it's heartbreaking because many of the
women um unlike you Mary ended up with
with with no children at all um so i'
I've I've seen a range of emotions um
some hidden emotions I think because is
an incredibly personal thing but other
delayed emotions where I've met people
after and clearly they had um you know
one one lady explained that she had um
closed her curtains after watching the
documentary I created for an entire
weekend cried her eyes out at age 50 I
believe and then come to terms finally
with the fact that she wasn't a mother
and she'd never done that before it was
all being held within her so there are a
lot of people who I think like you are
just completely unaware that they the
the body clock and it's not just the
body clock it's the ability to carry a
baby to term and the ability to have a
partner at that right moment I mean we
then to overlook that reality when we're
younger that's the thing there's just
things that go into having a kid the
partner the fertility and you're not
thinking of all those variables having
to come together no well we don't
prepare young people very well at all
and it's not just about the fertility
when you know we we tell young people I
think rightly to focus on Ed ation and
then focus on Career but we don't kind
of tell them that somewhere in the
amongst all of that You' have a few
other things that you might want to be
thinking about like finding the right
partner and planning as to when that
right time might be so and it's a
difficult balance especially for women
it's it's you know it's for me I I I'm
you know very aware that you know I'm a
male in this conversation it's certainly
not the same but hiding this from people
or you know simply ignoring it is it
doesn't benefit anybody Stephen when I
was reading your piece you know what
really jumped out to me is that apart
from big economic shocks which can put
people off having children because of
the financial um implications of that
which which makes a lot of sense there's
no obvious government public policy
that's going to encourage people to to
have more kids you you talk specifically
about finding a partner and I think that
that really jumped out to me because it
it it seemed from your research that
what you were finding um was that um you
say some women maybe aren't aware and
and Mary argues um you know that that
she wasn't really thinking about the
timeline there but there are lots of
women who will be aware of it they'll be
aware from it of it from a very young
age um but are simply struggling to find
that partner to have children with and
and to raise children with it is a huge
undertaking not just Financial but
emotional and personal um can you expand
a little bit on
that yeah well I I I I I empathize with
I think younger people today because I
think in today's environment it's if
anything getting more challenging I
think a general point I would make is
that um it is a general point but I feel
that as people get into their 30s it
gets harder to find that perfect match
when when you're younger um less people
are already in a relationship so
potentially there are more options to
choose from to find someone who you
might want to go on that life Journey
with but as you start to to advance
through life you've probably chosen the
the the town of City the place you want
to live by your 30s you've already got a
friend a friend group you've already
decided where you like to go on vacation
what your hobbies are so you're
narrowing down the specifics of what
person would match with your lifestyle
rather than creating that life together
so the idea that um it's fine I I'll
find someone when I get to that moment
in time it's not that simple you know
that's my core Point here that there's
always exceptions to this there's always
great stories about people having
children later in life meeting that
partner but those are more often not the
exception here I was just going to ask
might be the same as as what you're
asking K but I was going to ask about
dating apps I was wondering if I mean
I'd never used a date I just managed to
miss them which is great as my um but I
wondered if they incentivized men to
look for younger women um because you've
got this great catalog in front of you
you can always say no by the time you do
want to settle
down you know you perhaps you're you're
pushed to pick someone who is s of 25 I
mean 10 years younger than you so women
are being asked women are being told to
settle down later establish your career
but by the time they get to the bloke
the BLS of their generation are perhaps
looking younger is it do you find that
does that sound right I've heard a lot
of stories and most of them are very
challenging about dating apps you know
one fact that we mostly don't know is
that there are far more men on dating
apps than women so for men it's yeah
it's three to one um so for most men on
there you might get you know one
connection uh hit or whatever we call it
these days you know every few months if
you're lucky other men who are maybe the
right height looks income are getting
multiple options and that doesn't
benefit men or women because those men
are continually looking at the next
swipe um with little reason to to assume
that today's date is is the one uh women
are getting frustrated I think that
they're not finding men to settle down
with and there's a whole group of people
who who are not getting any dates at all
so there's a lot the things wrong with
that system Stephen in in some ways what
you and Mary are discussing right now
seems so simple prioritize finding a
partner you know go out there find a
decent person when you're on the younger
side and then you can set up your family
but I think you know for a lot of people
they'll hear that and they'll say well
I've I've been trying to do that or you
know I did pursue that and unfortunately
things didn't work out for me or you'll
have people in their 20s who are now
getting divorced in their 30s and 40s
saying you know I tried and that didn't
work out for me there is no State
solution to this there there is an
element of luck to all of this so what
is the actual prescription that you
would give to people uh when it comes to
addressing this partnership issue in
particular yeah you're right there is an
element of of of luck um in this for for
everyone and we we can't change that but
we can increase our chances
significantly if we become more open to
the idea men and women uh once we do
find someone who could be a potential
match for a
partner to you know have a family with
to be open to that instead of I think
this idea well let's date for three five
seven years and if everything kind of in
her life fits into place let let's say
at that point because frankly often what
happens is a divorce or the man finds
the 25y old um Etc so it's just being
aware and more open to will I think
inevitably inevitably increase the
chances for for for many people
Mary well Kate um the only thing that
occurs to me is to if you're looking to
get married and have a family perhaps
think of those qualities in mind with a
partner so you know we're all CH we're
all told to prioritize our life's
satisfaction and our pleasure and
happiness and you look for someone who's
sort of super hot or um successful you
know it it sounds funny but someone sort
of kind and dependable or someone you
might want to be a father to your
children is perhaps someone to go for
you know at an earlier age rather than
in a sort of panic later on and in fact
that is what really becomes attractive
after you've been ditched by serial
monogamists for for a while but
yeah Mary um we've explored this in in
the magazine um from from different
angles over the past few years um and I
wonder if we put so much emphasis on
women's understanding of their timeline
and their options understandably so of
course to a degree because it's their
bodies and ultimately they're going to
be the ones getting pregnant um but do
you think we do enough education for men
in this area to help them to understand
what these timelines realistically look
like and also their own fertility
struggles I mean it is also easier for
men when they're younger uh to to have
children than when they get older it's
not the same by any means um but do you
think sometimes we're disproportionate
in our focus in this conversation surely
it has to be a dialogue between the
Sexes I think mean an Ideal World it
would be and in an Ideal World men would
want to have children as much as women
but we I don't think that's the way
while biology works and it never has
been you know in my mother's generation
a lot of women you know got pregnant in
order to enforce a marriage in a family
because the guys weren't that into it um
so I just think biologically speaking
practically speaking um the conversation
is most productive when you have it with
women although perhaps you think it
shouldn't be that way um I think it is
could I just add in on the m i me one
thing dawned on me um that I don't think
too many men think through is that as
they get older if they're single they're
going to be competing with more and more
men for younger and younger women so it
gets harder so the fact that
technically we can become fathers late
in life um unless you are in a quite an
exceptional Le of you know Hollywood
alist or you know multi-millionaire
billionaire your chance are actually
pretty small and I've seen friends of
mine actually into their 40s who no
problem dating in their 30s are suddenly
finding they're not getting those dates
anymore no Stephen you write in the
piece um that you're actually somewhat
optimistic uh when it comes to the
deficit or the birth Gap why is
that um yeah and I didn't expect to be
um during the the documentary itself
really it was
um you know pessimism after pessimism
when you saw the economic challenges the
Social Challenges the
loneliness um what turned it around to
some extent is the reaction screening
the final film to to younger people have
screened it to 12 14 17 year olds
through college age people and the fire
in the eyes of those young people who I
think I would describe often feel anger
that that term has being used at
realizing that we us the adults haven't
actually thought this through you know
we're telling them do your homework
study get that you know education
training get on the career path all of
this and I think young people mostly are
assuming that we've thought this through
that that must mean that in their 30s
most likely than not more likely than
not they're going to be able to have the
family that they want to have when they
see people grieving the reality that
that didn't happen uh my finding is only
half of women turning 30 without a child
ever become a mother and that's
Global uh so you know I think young
people are going to make decisions there
uh I mean there's one beautiful
statement I'll share with you from a
21-year-old young Japanese woman who
just quietly said the documentary
changed her life and she didn't tell me
what it meant what she meant by that but
I assumed she meant she was going to
prioritize finding someone ahead of the
other pressures that Society puts on
yeah certainly young people but
certainly particularly women today and
Mary finally uh on the same point later
in the program I'm speaking to Laura
dodsworth who talks about the death of
chivalry but she's a bit optimistic she
thinks that changes she's seeing changes
in in the younger Generations um are you
seeing some of those changes are you as
optimistic as
Stephen I think so yes I mean I'm
excited by what Stephen says I think
certainly for my generation if you have
if you had kids young um there was a
sort of stigma about that like you
weren't clever or you didn't have a
career option we were also so pushed to
you know and and and that's what I
think's you know got to change um
because obviously having a kid is
fabulous um so maybe if if that can
change if the stigma drops then I'm I'm
hopeful Stephen and Mary it's nice to
end on an optimistic note thanks for
joining
me and finally would you give up your
seat for a lady on the TU this week
Laura dodsworth writes for The Spectator
about the death of chivalry she joins me
now
Laura thanks for joining spectator TV
you've written a brilliant piece for
spectator life about why chivalry is
dead do you think it can ever come back
from the grave yes I think it can look
I'll be honest I don't think it's
completely dead um I think I may have
said in the article it's actually
incinerated um and sometimes it can feel
like that but it's not completely dead
look my my teenage Sons I I told them
about what happened to me and they were
both astonished they said they still
offer their seats for ladies for the Eld
so you know some people are still doing
it let's dive into what happened to you
you had a horrible experience on the
tube it wasn't just that this gentleman
although I think that's a rich
description of him probably too generous
it's not just that he wouldn't give up
his seat he wouldn't move his
bag I know it was so funny I actually
thought he was joking so it it might
seem a bit Petty to hook a whole article
onto one experience but what it was for
me was this nail in the coffin of
chivalry so picture the scene it's hot I
mean it's like a furnace it's the
underground I've been wearing heels all
day got a little bit of sciatica I'm
tired I'm tired and there were no spare
seats but this one gentleman um had a
suitcase in a bag on a seat next to him
so I got to him and I politely say
excuse me would you mind moving your bag
so I can sit down and he he took a he
took a slug from his can of beer and he
looked at me and he said no I said what
really I thought it was a joke and he
said it's a priority seat SE for
luggage which it which it was but
nothing makes you feel like more of an
old bag than when a man won't move his
bag for you I just thought it was
incredible because I wasn't asking for
his seat I was asking for his suitcase
his seat and actually next to him was a
young lady uh nothing to do with him and
she she sprang out of her seat and she
said oh would you like my
seat but I've got to say by this stage I
didn't actually want to sit next to him
you know you acquire a kind of an
inbuilt radar over the years if if a man
gives off a funny sort of vibe if he
seems aggressive you don't want to put
yourself next to him you're going to the
other side of the carriage the other
side of the carriage not sitting next to
him and his um his very tired suitcase
but this this young woman and I end up
looking at each other you know our eyes
kind of widening with shock and talking
about the fact that chivalry was dead um
and you know the week after another
incident happened which sort of cemented
it for me I was on an even more crowded
Carriage so crowded that I couldn't go
over and March over to help this woman
but she was wearing a mask which of
course no one's doing anymore and she
had not hair on her head and I thought
it looks to me like she's undergoing
chemotherapy or some kind of medical
treatment nobody offered her a seat
nobody and she looked quite shaky and I
was so upset to see somebody who's not
just in heels and is a middle-aged woman
but someone who's unwell obviously
unwell not being given a seat and I
think that's the thing about chivalry um
although we think of it as a courtesy
that men extend to women I think it's
more than that I think that there's a
general courtesy and tolerance and
kindness which has been it's been killed
off over the years yes I I think this is
a important point because we often think
of chivalry in the context of a
relationship a romantic relationship how
people treat one another but it
certainly doesn't have to be in that
context really it's fundamental chivalry
is good manners which it seems from your
two experiences a lot of people are
lacking yeah I think think so I mean I
think something has changed I don't
quite know when the Rocks set in but I
do think that women are partly to blame
I'm not I'm not going to say that
feminism is completely killed off
chivalry but I think that's a part of it
you see chivalry um I mean it's it's an
old medieval code isn't it it comes from
sh shal code where Knights would honor
women help the poor be brave Etc and I
think a lot of feminists the felt that's
incompatible with feminism which in a
way it is because if you treat the sex
as different ly that's the literal
definition of sexism or sexual
discrimination you're treating them
differently and of course baked in to
the idea of chivalry is that men who are
the dominant sex would protect the
weaker sex of course that's how it was
then now A lot's changed and I think
that women have made a mistake in
thinking that they need to respect these
sorts of courtesies that men extend to
them now I used to do it I used to do it
all the time I would say no if somebody
offered me a seat I think actually as a
young woman you get offered a seat more
than when you're older that's my
experience anyway but I would say no I
don't know if I actually Sneed at men or
said educate yourself but I bet I was
giving off that Vibe hands up um I
didn't need I didn't need a man to open
a door for me I didn't need him to carry
a bag I didn't want his seat now I'm 50
I kind of do I appreciate it I love the
fact that my sons are tall enough to
reach things off the high shelf or they
they carry things without me asking
because there is a respect in which the
Sexes are different we are physically
different and I think that ackn
knowledging that and being courteous
about it is is a good thing it shouldn't
be seen as an insult I think that that
particular brand of feminism that I used
to to have to exude when I was younger
came from a lack of
experience and I think that feminism
malfunctioned as it were when I had
children because there's no bigger
reminder of your difference than when
you're pregnant you give birth and you
breastfeed and you are reliant basically
normally
on on the man to be the provider and to
look after you for a period of time um I
think so I think that was that was a big
change for me and I think the other
thing that I've noticed is this General
lack of courtesy which is I say about
more than a difference between men and
women it's something that's crept into
um all aspects of public life and it's
really sad I think we do need to
resurrect
chivalry um you know your article got me
thinking about my own experiences and my
conversations with my girlfriends in my
20s as opposed to my 30s and I really
resonate with what you're saying that
there was certainly a time where the
attitude was you know we're absolutely
going to split the bill he's absolutely
not opening the door because I have to
show my Independence and I just think
when you become a bit more nuanced about
it all it's kind of people just
thoughtfully indicating to each other
that they care or that they value
somebody or in the in the sense of
strangers just that they're doing a nice
thing you know you get home at the end
of the day and you think gosh I I was
helpful um you know I I was a decent
person on the tube I was a decent person
on on the bus um and I I agree with you
I think that that women should bear some
of the responsibility I do Wonder
however Laura if men should bear a bit
more of the responsibility I think it's
um been very convenient perhaps for some
men uh that um the expectation has been
taken off of them um and that they
perhaps don't feel so inclined now that
they don't feel like um it's expected
your sons obviously uh being the counter
example here
and I think there are lots of them I
mean I I shared this article on LinkedIn
it was nice to share something that was
I thought a bit lighter than my normal
fair but my goodness this has got men
really angry um I think a lot of people
they've done that thing of they've read
the title and they haven't read the
article so there are lots of men
complaining on my LinkedIn that chivalry
is dead and it's women's fault I'm like
yes yes sir read the article um and I
think that there is a certain brand of
man like my tube o who feels quite happy
and entitled to sit on the seat I think
he's glad the expectation gone I don't
think it ever suited him in the first
place he loves planting his backside on
the mock seats rather than a noble Steed
he's very happy to have a beer can and
not a sword in his hand he looked pretty
comfortable and he had no shame at all
about telling me I couldn't have a seat
he had no idea what my need might be or
whether I was Ill nothing yeah so there
is a certain kind of person who is
taking this and running with it but then
if I'm going to put some criticism onto
men it's that they need to toughen up a
little bit now I talked to one chap I
know about this story and he said well
yeah I used to offer my seat and I don't
anymore because women kept turning me
down and you know if they've come across
a few women who were like Laura when she
was 18
1920 they may be thinking well you know
screw you I offered you a seat and I'm
not doing it again and you can stand
but the thing about courtesy and
kindness is you shouldn't be knocked
back so easily just keep going that's
that's the way to resurrect it people
can ReDiscover their own manners um
otherwise what you get is a you know we
want a circle of love we don't want to
be passing on negativity the whole time
you know you talked about coming home
and you feel I helped somebody there's
no greater feeling is there but you have
to pay it forward you have to keep
spreading it around yeah yeah and not
everybody's going to ask certainly
actually most people aren't going to ask
and you have to be prepared to have your
kindness rejected but it's a risk that I
think you know I ideally you you want to
take um Laura I suppose my my last
question to you if I may is is you say
your sons are are growing up to to learn
about chivalry do you think there's
going to be a reverse here do you think
perhaps um women realizing that they
have a role to play in this are now
correcting and they're going to be
raising their sons to be the next
chivalrous generation perhaps there's
something to look forward to
I don't know I think there's all kinds
of Corrections that are going on
actually so thinking not just about my
sons but all the teenage boys I'm
exposed to through
them while I'd say they've got their
manners about them I think a lot of
young men are actually they're kind of
swinging the other way they're they're
frightened of what happens between men
and women will a woman pin a complaint
upon them will she say that uh they
looked at her the wrong way I mean you
got to remember on the tube there have
been posters up as well saying that
staring is an unwanted intrusion I mean
it's gone quite far it's quite hard for
young men now to know how they should
behave because they're told that even
looking at a woman is wrong and you know
I heard uh one young man say not not my
sons but another said he he would be
scared of making a move on a woman
unless she's written down first that he
can so I think that um there are all
kinds of swings and Corrections going on
and it's not all good otherwise you
wouldn't see the rise of a phenomenon as
well like Andrew Tay who's pushing a
really kind of hyper masculine brodo
version of masculinity I don't think
there' have been enough good male role
models to be honest high-profile
masculine ra role models for young men
and that's that's the role of men to
take up that role actually I think
that's um that's a very good point
because you know it especially when it
comes to role models celebrities and the
rest of it I mean I am still in shock
and awe when I discover that a celebrity
couple has been together for 25 years
that shouldn't be surprising but um this
idea that to be strong to be masculine
to be chivalrous um is to show respect
to women and to treat women well and
you're right unfortunately those Role
Models do feel like they've been been
dwindling and I guess we we just really
need to go back to basics
here we do shivalry the sh
code Laura thanks so much for joining
spectator
TV and that's it for this week once
again if you do enjoy spectator TV
subscribe to our YouTube channel just
click the Subscribe button at the bottom
of this video and tap the Bell icon to
make sure you never miss an episode I
would also like to thank our sponsors
again can oford genuity wealth
management can oford our experienced
wealth planners and investment managers
who offer unwavering support during
challenging times visit kendow
wealth.com for more information thanks
again for watching and do join us again
next
[Music]
week